.
IS THAT GOING TO HELP OUR
COUNTRY DEAL WITH THESE
MIGRANTS?
WE DO HAVE MARK GREEN BACK.
CAN YOU HEAR ME, CONGRESSMAN?
>> YEAH.
I GOT YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
YOU GUYS HEAR ME OKAY?
>> Todd: WE HEAR YOU, SIR.
BESIDES THE IMPEACHMENT OF
MAYORKAS, WHAT ARE THE FIRST
STEPS YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO DO IN
CONGRESS TO SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
>> WELL, THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS WE CAN DO.
SOME OF THE FIRST STEPS ARE TO,
OF COURSE, REQUEST INFORMATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE
CAN GO AND HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THE
CRAZY LAWS, DERELICTION OF DUTY
FROM THE SECRETARY.
WE CAN ALSO PASS LEGISLATION
THAT SUPPORTS THE FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGES TO COUNTRIES IN CENTRAL
AMERICA.
AND ACTUALLY HAS THEM IMPLEMENT
THE MPP.
THEY CAN ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
START PUTTING PEOPLE BACK INTO
THE COUNTRIES THAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY COME FROM.
SO, THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO IT.
>> Carley: CONGRESSMAN PAT
FALLON MADE BIG TIME NEWS
YESTERDAY BY FILING ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT AGAINST ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS.
IT'S SOMETHING A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WANT TO SEE BUT
REALISTICALLY, IS THAT GOING
ANYWHERE.
>> SO WHAT WE HAVE GOT TO DO IS
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
MY COMMITTEE IS NOT THE
JURISDICTION FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S THE JEWISH AREA
COMMITTEE.
OF MY JOB WILL BE TO GO GET THE
DETAILS.
SENDING LETTERS OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
WE'LL SUBPOENA EMAILS.
ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF.
AND DO THE DUE DILIGENCE.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SECRETARY MAYORKAS COME IN AND
LOOK AT THE LAWS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN ENFORCED.
WE'RE GOING TO INFORM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THE
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN WASTED
WITH NGO CONTRACTS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO, A LOT OF -- A LOT OF THINGS
WE'RE GOING TO BE DIGGING INTO.
AND THEN, IF IT LOOKS LIKE HE
NEEDS TO BE IMPEACHED.
WE WILL HAND THAT OFF TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> Carley: WE SHOULD HAVE
STARTED OFF CONGRATULATION
TOWELS AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
YOU HAVE YOUR WORK CUT OUT TO
YOU ESPECIALLY WHEN IT DOES COME
TO THE BORDER.
96 PEOPLE ON THE TERROR WATCH
LIST WERE CAUGHT TRYING TO COME
NOT COUNTRY WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION THROUGH THOSE PORTS
WHERE THERE IS NO BORDER
DEPENDING HOW MANY PEOPLE WANT
TO DO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HOME
GET THROUGH?
SO HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE?
>> SO, THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS, RIGHT?
SO WE NEED NEW TECHNOLOGY.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR CBP
FOLKS.
THEY ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
RETAINING PERSONNEL AND ALSO
HIRING NEW PERSONNEL.
AND SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS A
POLICY GOFF FORMER VETERAN WHO
HAS TO GO THROUGH THIS VERY
ARDUOUS PROCESS TO GET HIRED,
AND, YOU KNOW, IF WE HAVE GOT A
VETERAN WHO HAD A SUCCESSFUL
MILITARY CAREER, WHY DON'T WE
PUT THEM IN CBP.
IT'S SIMPLE THINGS LIKE THAT
VERY QUICKLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Carley: INTERESTING.
>> WE GOT TAKE CONTROL BACK FROM
THE DRUG CARTELS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN CONTROL
TO THE DRUG CARTELS WITH THE
MASSIVE WAVES OF PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE CROSSING SITES.
FENTANYL POURS.
IN WE CAN ADDRESS THIS BY OUR
AUTHORIZING REGULATION THAT
DEMANDS THAT THE DHS FOLKS DO IT
THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
DONE.
>> Todd: YOU ARE CHAIR OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
WILL OUR HOMELAND BE MORE SECURE
THAN IT WAS THE PAST TWO YEARS.
>> # HUNDRED PERCENT.
YES.
>> Todd: CONGRESSMAN MARK GREEN,